what makes a city people buildings
horrific traffic jams that's not too far
off it turns out that wrote or what
connect all the parts of a city we need
easy paths to travel from place to place
and for moving materials supplies and
services and in some parts of cities
slums that's not happening
the world's slums lack not only large
easy to travel roads but they're also
missing a lot of the infrastructure that
goes along with them street signs
building numbers and vehicle access to
building exterior that lack of
connectivity means that the billion
people living in slums can't reliably
get their mail get to work or even get
to the hospital in an emergency trash
removal and sanitation are difficult at
best now scientists are trying to
transform slums with a mathematical
approach to urban design called topology
slums can be broken down into two
components infrastructure like homes and
stores and the access network that links
them nodes and connections with this
framework connections in effect access
can be optimized
[Music]
this new approaches already been used in
two slums within Cape Town South Africa
in one of the two neighborhoods most
essential services provided by the city
water toilets electricity trash removal
are on the outskirts where road access
exists but the inner portions of the
settlement where temples are are
completely cut off in this study
scientists use satellite data and
detailed maps handmade by locals to
diagram all the nodes and connections of
the settlement they then use their
topological algorithm to figure out
which areas were inaccessible by roads
then generated the most cost effective
ways to build roads and connect them to
outside services in topology since one
block of buildings surrounded by roads
is considered equivalent settlements
with a wide range of shapes and sizes
from the suburbs of Las Vegas to the
slums of Mumbai can be analyzed in the
same way the scientists who designed the
program hope to come up with a
user-friendly interface that can be used
by communities around the world that
they say would put the decision-making
power into the hands of locals who can
determine if proposed access roads will
accommodate their priorities then
reroute them accordingly
[Music]